e
e e
okay it being 2011 this is division
we'll open the hearing uh or the meeting
a better word for it I guess um this is
uh the finance committee division 2 and
we have the Department of Education with
us today so I'll let them take it
away and please introduce
yourselves Melissa white division
director for learner support at New
Hampshire Department of Education and we
have uh several folks here today to
present on a variety of programs and so
we were going to start off um with the
office of nutrition program and services
and I'll hand it over to Kelly
Rambo good afternoon Kelly Rambo Bureau
administrator for um wellness and
nutrition at the Department of
Education um so in front of you you'll
have um a packet with um what I thought
might be helpful information for for you
all to have um and I'll start just by
saying that the cover page of um the
packet is um are all of the programs
that the office does um Monitor and um
work on within the
department and um flipping to the next
page um for just for your reference um
oh I'm sorry can you as you go through
you when you switch Pages could just
tell us what page you're on so I I can
follow along more easily sure okay so
this is the packet
okay um so we're going to turn to page
um one and I apologize if the the
numbers um okay great great um so the um
first page here page one and um page two
are um just a a brief overview of the
programs um and how they they relate to
to the department um so you can see that
we oversee the national school lunch
program um which is the the one that
might be known best um at here and then
um with within that we have the fresh
fruit and vegetable program um Community
eligibility or C as it's also known um
the after school snack program turning
over to the second page page two um the
office also oversees the food for the
child and adult care food program so um
that might be something that um you
might not be aware of that this office
although they're licensed at DHHS this
office does oversee the food portion of
that program um and then the summer food
service program and those are all of the
programs that take place during the the
months that school is not in session and
we also offer the special milk program
um and these programs are all federally
funded through the USDA US Department of
Agriculture um and
100% um completely all federal funds
there you'll see um in in the next few
pages there are some supplemental State
funds that do um come with the the
programs um flipping to page three um
the next three pages are going to be the
federal reimbursement rates depending on
what program they are um so the first
page page three in front of you is the
national school lunch program and those
are the the federal reimbursement rates
for um July 1 they work up the the state
um fiscal year so July 1 to June 30th um
and there is um flipping to page four
there's a little bit um more
comprehensive breakdown of what the
reimbursement rate is for the federal um
and then you can see the state portion
that's um in that calculation as well
too any questions on and that is just
related to the rates there are just
related to the school l reimbursal
program that's correct
yes repres
papic Mr chair and thank you for being
here I'm just looking at the page three
the SEC the severe need
launch two
cents why do the feds do you have any
idea why the feds consider an additional
two cents to be U addressing a severe
need lunch um I would like to be able to
speak to that but unfortunately I'm not
sure of their um algorithm on figuring
that out thank you I'm just trying to
avoid any uh two cents worth jokes here
so I'll be quiet now thank
you so on the next page will you talked
about the the breakdown for the
breakfast lunch doesn't have any
breakdown does that imply that it's
totally Federal that's correct there is
a a state um match that is paid through
lunch but that is a set amount that we
um get every year that's within our our
budget um but the the breakfast portion
is based upon the meal and so that's why
I broke it out in that way because
that's depending upon how many meals are
served that um and there's a chart in
here that'll show you um comparison of
last year on how much was paid out
federally um for the meals that were
served so the lunch just say they give
you a black Grant of some amount of
money unrelated to the number of meals
you serve that's correct thank
you question okay um so moving on to
page five um these are the reimbursement
rates for the child and adult care um
food program again these rates are um as
of July 1 to June
30th um and these are dependent upon um
there's a number of items that that go
into um how they're determined at the
the sponsor level um for for the child
and adult care
program and then um flipping to page six
these are the reimbursement rates um you
know USDA wouldn't be um USDA unless
they thre a curve um in here so the the
summer rates are actually um calendar
year um so you can see that at the top
and those are from um January to to
December um and these were actually um
hot off the press just just released um
to get into the packet for for this
coming summer that we're we have already
started working on um
rep Murray thank you very much um I
don't want to open up a can of worms but
last year last budget cycle there was
confusion about the summer program and I
was saying you know that the the this
program provides meals for students
during the school year but because the
program had money throughout the year
people seem to be confused that they
were thinking that oh but they're
they're still getting fed during the
summer it's like no they're actually not
and and that money goes you know it's
what the parents have to pay to pick it
up and we were trying to have remember
the feed the kids program and it's just
it was having a hard time trying to
understand that the kids are still going
to have lunch in the summer but it's not
covered by this program even though the
program's dispersed throughout the year
can you know what I'm talking about can
you speak to that a little bit because
it got very confusing and it was we're
trying to make the point that the cost
goes back onto the parents if we didn't
have this program for the summer so can
you just sure make it clearer than I can
I I think within the the last two year
two or three years there is um a new
program um that USDA has come up with
which is sebt or summer EBT so that
program is completely separate um that
is um a program that's operated through
DHHS Department of Health and Human
Services so this um summer food service
program has certain qualifications on
whether a um a site whether that be um a
brick and mortar building or or a um a
camp site um an outdoor site on how they
qualify so so there's certain parameters
in that so there are some um schools or
brick and mortar buildings that might
not qualify per the USDA um regulations
to um offer meals at what we call no
cost to to those students so um it and a
site might be open and what that means
is that that any child can go go to that
location um they don't have to go to
school there but is an open sight where
a child can go and get a meal during
those summer months um so does that does
that help yeah thank you it was just
there was for some people there seemed
to be a gap that uh not understanding
that you know these are children who
have a need and if it's not provided by
these programs it needs to be provided
by the parents which is an additional
burden for a family that is already
dealing with poverty issues and that you
know children do have lunch in the
summertime and it doesn't end at the end
of the school year but um it was just I
would like to avoid uh going down that
rabbit hole this year if we can by
making trying to help people understand
that this is that summer program to feed
the children so and we do have um put
together a map of where those summer
sites are so once they are approved in
our um in through our office then we do
put that map out so and that's publicly
so you can click on that map it's
interactive to show um there's also a
phone number that you can call to say
where is the closest place for me to get
a a summer um summer meal and it and
again it might not be at a brick and
mortar building school but the open
sight might be um you know at a at a
playground or or what that that might
look
like repres papovich thank you Mr chair
just to make sure I understood this
because it is obviously a very important
topic I understand
that most kids will have access through
food throughout the summer they just got
to figure out what the proper site to
collect the lunch is you were saying
that a few sites may not be qualified
would that prevent any kids from getting
these lunches or will they just have to
go to maybe another site that's less
convenient I'm trying to understand what
the impact of those sites that may not
be qualified is on you know the ability
of kids and their parents to access this
sure um and thank you for the the
question there um for for those brick
and mortar buildings that that don't
qualify um and if there is another open
site that is near um you know where that
child might live they can go to that
site there are some locations that are
um that do operate a summer program but
they're closed sites which means that
those therefore enrolled students that
might be a YMCA or something along along
those lines but um and that's all
labeled in the map whether it's an open
site whether it's a closed site um and
and again that map um does come out
around um June or July um because we
have to go through the application
process to to ensure that they do
qualify um to
operate so is the S fsp program the
closed site program um it's a mix it's
mixed um so the summer food service
program depending upon on um your
application and what location you submit
for it could be an open site it could be
a closed site there are um specific
things that we look for in the
application process so you can qualify
for either or both the
sfsp and the or the
SBT I go ahead so the EBT is a separate
program and so that's where they receive
their electronic benefits on um I think
it's a card system and so that is
separate and not part of this program so
if you have I think the there's
confusion between the two things being
the same and there separate benefits
programs okay so so the pop-up thing had
nothing to do with the EBT thing that
was part of the fsp thing okay so then
explain to me
the difference in qualification between
the fsp program and the EBT program
they're both deal is something that DHHS
would determine the qualifications on
who those families or student
participants are are our program would
be separate from that in our
determination I thought you said you
managed it or something no we don't do
we do not manage EBT oh that's just DHS
DHS DHS do they overlap might they
overlap we are required to have um a
memorandum of understanding I think it
is um because it is also a program that
I think the USDA is promoting and so the
requirements to receive funding require
us to coordinate our efforts together
but they are two separate programs okay
and how do you coordinate them so I'll
let you speak to that a little bit more
it's really mostly through data sharing
but sure um it operates in the same way
that we um currently have anou for those
students that are directly certified um
from DHHS that that come over to us um
so it operates in in the same way that
um we would do data sharing um between
the two and that's what the
states and is the implication that with
that amendment of understanding you all
know how to divy things up so that
you're handling a group and they're
handling a group and they're independent
so
um summer um SBT or summer EBT is fully
operational at um at
DHHS if I I think I I which one's it
DHHS EBT EBT okay I said said the other
one okay yeah um and so they handle all
all of that um and they have certain um
qualifications and application processes
specific for that program um and then
the summer food service
program we is summer food service
program provides the meal so at the site
we are providing that meal to that
student whereas EBT is those are funds
that are provided to that
family so you could qualify for both
that's all I'm trying to understand yes
yes okay thank
you question okay um so so those are the
reimbursement rates um and um flipping
to page
seven um so this chart just gives a um
analysis of the meals that were served
from last school year based on the free
or reduced or um P what USDA calls paid
status um you can see that the federal
reimbursement rate there's a column for
federal reimbursement rate there's a
column for State reimbursement rate and
then the total of State funding that was
paid out um and then the total of
federal funding that was paid out the
top section is for breakfast and then
the bottom section is for lunch um and
then at the complete bottom of the page
you can see the total amount that was
paid out for fy2 for um for state and
also Federal and keep in mind this um
this one is just for the national school
lunch program I thought having that
comparison and the numbers broken down
for that program would be um would be
beneficial go represent
papovich thank you Mr chair looking on
page seven I'm looking at um the last
the bottom line of the spreadsheet the
state lunch part yes you know when when
you look at breakfast the state State
fing is broken down between the various
types of meals the state lunch does not
seem to be broken down can you help me
understand why sure um the the state
lunch is based on um a match amount and
if you look at the the aster that's on
the bottom that corresponds with the
breakfast and lunch um that is broken
down in RSA 189
111a if I
may thank you so just to better
understand it um the state essentially
provides the same reimbursement for any
type of lunch so you guys didn't break
it down by free lunch reduced lunch or
100% not fnr that's correct it's based
on a dollar amount that um then is based
on a formula that is given back to to
the schools but if I wanted to break it
down I could just do it proportionally
based on the number of meals
served um NOP but if you wanted that
breakdown I could get it for you I don't
think I would like to request that at
this time cuz I'm not sure how
meaningful that is I'm just trying to
understand how the system works for now
so I don't want to create more work at
this time thank
you so what is the difference between
free lunch reduced lunch 100% fnr lunch
and state lunch is it different kids
qualifying for different programs so um
the the meal type is based on the USDA
um regulations on um and that the free
lunch is for um 13 30% up to Poverty
Level the free lunch is 185 up to
Poverty Level reduced lunch I mean um
excuse me the reduced lunch thank you
and then anything over that um is cons
what's considered a paid lunch and then
the paid lunch prices are configured at
the local level and then what's the
state lunch is it independent of those
other three um the the state lunch is
just a dollar amount that's that's not
um that's just saying that the state
pays this much amount for um the lunch
match
okay representative Murray um for the
lunch part uh the state pays
nothing we pay for the breakfast we
don't pay for lunch so all programs and
states that participate in the USDA
programs have to have some sort of State
match and so they determine what our
matches and then we have the our the
wellness part that's considered in RSA
1891 11a that three cents and then the
30 cents so the state has to put up a
portion we use that and say okay this is
our match for those federal dollars to
be able to keep coming in so we couldn't
reduce that down because then we
wouldn't be meeting the requirements and
they definitely want to make sure that
we keep that that match going but
looking at this it appears that we use
that match for
breakfast not for lunch lunch is all
zeros for the state
no no the matches for both you have to
it's cumulative so the and there's
different programs so the breakfast
program the food program the milk
program there's all separate programs
that have
requirements but the match that's there
by state lunch only applies to
lunch so that's matching the free lunch
reduced lunch 100% non Lun Federal parts
so that yeah so this was the amount that
was paid out for last year to match the
federal funds that we received for the
program that's why there's no um that's
why there's no 3 cents no 30 cents we
had to meet a match for the federal
funds that we we received and that's
what that comes from I understand that
I'm trying to understand which federal
dollars you're matching is it simply
matching the free lunch Federal plus the
reduced lunch Federal plus the 100% non
fnr lunch federal or is it a more
generalized match across this whole
thing it's it's cumulative across the
whole thing it's not specific to um
any meal that is being served the reason
why I I get that part but under the
breakfasts there is a specific
meal-based match correct right so is
this match also on top of that or is a
component of that so it's on top of it
and the the formula again that I could
get for you is that we have this dollar
amount we do take um meals that were
served in a certain month from that year
and then allocate that back to to the
schools so there is a Formula that is
done um I just wanted you to have a
total picture of when you looked at a
budget and you know we were only
allocating because we took to
consideration the RSA um that you would
look at your budget line of how much was
spent in this line I wanted you to see
that we did in fact spend
800,000 um okay that's a good way to put
it in terms of the the lines so there's
a line in the budget for State lunch
correct okay and there's also three
lines in the budget for breakfast as far
as the states
concerned the 51 million the 955 million
the 60 million is that an accurate
statement yes it it is in um it's all in
one class but um it is allocated into
that yes so they go ahead no you you I
say just say you said again I'm sorry um
so it is allocated in the budget in one
class so it's class 601 is the breakfast
and then 602 um is where the lunch match
portion is in there in the budget okay
uh repr so when we look at the budget
we'd see the 832 for lunch in one line
and the 200 something for the breakfast
Consolidated in another line and this is
just the breakdown of how you got to
that Consolidated breakfast total
correct thank you and the very last
question on this topic because it's
already a lot if I yes you you may have
l that 8:32 is a match just for the
lunch programs correct regardless of the
nature of the meal but it's only for
lunch so the 200 is for the breakfast
800 something for lunch and that's how
we get to a million plus here that's
correct done thank you so that's great
when you do come back with the when we
start going through these things you
could call our attention to the lines
that you're referring to at that point
okay yes thank you very
much um so flipping to page eight
this chart is not broken down in as much
detail as the the other chart um but I
did want you to see the federal funding
that has um gone through the the office
um for fy22 23 and 24 and these are
based upon um the USDA programs um so
obviously in 22 that was during covid
you can see the um the dollar amount
that was pushed out for that um in FY 23
there were um still some waivers um
during that time so you can see that the
the cost is still um higher and then
obviously in FY 24 um you know we've
dropped down on on federal funds for
that so are these programs strictly
federal funds these ones you have here
yes be with the exception of the
national school lunch program and that's
the one on page seven that has the
detail broken into it that has the state
portion um in there so that's why the
that's why page um seven was broken down
more um so that you can see the state
portion in there so so that's great but
it would have been nice to see you got
more years here would have been nice to
see the general funds across the years
as well that's okay I can do you don't
need to change anything but when you
come back okay uh yes representative
Dy why is it
72 million during Co the um USDA covered
all meals for all students so you didn't
have to have an income qualifier all
meals were covered all meals all meals
for all students very strange that it
didn't matter anymore is it because the
children don't get the meals at home is
that probably part of the I I think they
had a very a number of reasons why they
provided meals to to all students so
that was for that school year covering
um it's going across because the fiscal
year is covering a couple of uh school
years because it's kind of right in the
middle so that's why an y 23 we're still
at almost 48 million because it was
considering a portion of that school
year where those meals were still free
FY 24 is when we come back into really
enacting the law prior to
covid where there were the income
guidelines in place can I follow up um
did this include delivering the meals to
the people at home the students at home
or did they have to come to the school
no they had to come to the schools to
pick come to the school thank you
um and just on on that that point as
well too um as Melissa stated in fy22
meals were reimbursed at the free rate
so that's why the the that's why the
federal funds is so high and as we go
back into um FY 23 and 24 the
applications need to be filled out and
the meals were then being um reimbursed
at the free reduced and paid rates that
you see in the um the previous
Pages um
so flipping to page nine to um this
report here so 9
through um 32 this oh okay um so this
report um is the the current um free and
reduced eligibility rates um for you at
thought it would be a good um document
for you to have this is also on our
website
um so I won't go specifically through
that but um I thought it would be
helpful representa muray thank you just
a quick question do you see much
fluctuation um across you know within
the school district of students who
qualify or don't qualify is there a lot
of fluctuation or not between um fiscal
years or years when they yeah when
they're in the program when they're out
of the program
um I think that we we have seen
obviously coming from from covid to to
now that there there um you know it it
does depend on um if the the
applications are are getting filled out
at the local level um there number of
factors that that could come into play
on there um whether they receive
benefits through um a DHHS program snap
or tanif and and though they're directly
identified through those programs um so
yes there is a fluctuation um you know
depending upon um the the school
district or how many applications that
they have gone gotten
back just quick thank you um I guess
what I'm looking for is if um you
potentially would see an uptick if uh a
rise of poverty um across the school
district um if that would show up in
here that's not what you're looking for
I'm just curious in terms of data that
this might be um another track or
another indication of of poverty in an
area I think there was a challenge
because um when there was no requirement
to fill out applications I know that was
reported um from school districts that
they were having difficulty getting um
families to go back to um filling those
out so we've actually I think saw maybe
a little bit
less so it's hard to to make a
correlation there
because it could have gone up but we
wouldn't be able to tell because there's
less applications being
F
out so this is a non-trivial thing to
search through isn't it it's not
by seu numbers it's not by alphabetical
it's just sort of throwing things
together
alphabetical no I believe the the
district is in alphabetical order it's
coordinated by the school because that's
so so take a district like where you're
at John Stark and you got the the where
and then you but the but the SAU
includes um uh Stoddard and uh another
one hener and something else I think yes
what do you call
that but it would be listed by school
name of school I hener Community School
no no name of school and where uh hker
Community School uh in Haner Center
Woods
Elementary okay and how about the one
that's where Middle School midd school
you think that's in here it should be at
the W's
Maybe is that supposed to be the end or
is it could have be somewhere
else no I think it's listed
under I see Henrik her office I see
White
Mountains I see Wilton I see Windam I
see
winnisquam we can also get this report
for you in Excel if that's helpful oh
that'd be great um you somebody must
have told you what I like that'd be
fantastic if you everything you can get
me in Excel I'd prefer thank you
yes page 27 where District
total listed under hener SAU
office yeah I think we have it actually
organized by
uh
number District number yeah
y okay
it'll say the district
total so what is that
15 I will send this to you in Excel so
you can sort sort As You Wish um so um
if there's no question further questions
on that um flipping to page
33 um I thought that this again might
just be um a helpful one-page document
for you um all to just have a little bit
more information on the community
eligibility um program um also known as
c um because I know there have been some
um some questions about about that
program
um and then flipping to um page 34 again
again just for
oh were you done with that page yes but
if you have a question
I I'm
not maybe just a little more detail so
what is that as respect everything else
sure um so I apologize I this is my I
have to admit most of these folks are
not new to the committee except for
myself and representative Kelly and
representative Roy so sure I'll be happy
to to speak about um c a little bit more
so um the community eligibility
provision program um we currently have
three schools in New Hampshire on this
program and it takes your um directly
identified students and uses that
percentage um and takes it to then be
able to offer um meals to students at a
certain percentage paid by the federal
government and then the other portion
needs to be paid by non-federal funds um
and I thought it was to put this in here
um I know there's been some conversation
about C in the community eligibility
program um and so they the calculation
percentage is um or the calculations
formula excuse me um is on here um it
also goes into detail on what the
identified students what who those
entail um and the um percentage to
qualify um was recently reduced to 25%
from 40%
um and so that would mean that um
schools that have 25% or higher are
eligible to participate in this program
there is another um application process
that we go through for verification of
that um but that's what that means for
for that program and does this interact
with the other programs or are they
independent what's the relationship you
so you would need to be on the national
school lunch program in order to qualify
for um for eligibility for this program
and this program then
provides more than those programs nope
so um so this program would provide a
additional subsidy federal subsidy um
for additional meals at no cost for for
a certain percentage of your students um
but the other side of of this program is
that then um the the the students are
not actually paying for the meal but the
meal um needs to be paid for by somebody
so um who who is that so is that um you
know coming from from the taxpayers or
um for that District or it does need to
be paid with non-federal funds so let's
take for example you had uh a community
that said okay we want to participate in
C they go in they identify maybe 40% of
their population would qualify so 40%
the other 60% would need to be covered
by the school or the Local District so
they're going to offer 100% free meals
to everybody 60% or 40% I'm sorry would
come from the feds the other 60% would
then be paid for at the local level so
the IDE is to cover everybody as opposed
to just a correct so the kids all get
the free meals you have to give everyone
a free meal but you have to make sure
then that you have some sort of way to
identify your percentage of poverty so
this gets a little bit different because
you can't cannot use the free and
reduced applications so there has to be
some other way to qualify and identify
those students so what we found is by
dropping it to
25% to
qualify can be a challenge if the local
level cannot cover the 75% cost of the
meals so it can be you know it works
very well I think for um communities
that have a very high percentage o of
poverty so if you're looking at 85% of
your community um qualifies and then the
local levels only having to cover maybe
15% it that program works out incredibly
well for those communities because then
and those families don't you know have
to to qualify for those reduced kids
that might go in and out between you
know that qualifying number but when
you're looking at you know a community
that maybe only has 25% the local level
having to cover 75% can be a cost that
they need to make you know a decision at
at the local level as to whether they
can cover that or nots on
papish thank you Mr chair given what
you're saying which by the way makes
absolutely complete sense right the
higher the percentage the more
worthwhile the CP is because you have
more kids that benefit fewers you got to
carry for and you reduce the paperwork
by massive amount if it's a large number
of
kids when the barrier for eligibility
was reduced from 40 to 25 did you see
any districts who are in the 25 to 40
range actually join the program yet no
no no we did thank you I thought so um
because although it does that it does
lower the um the percentage for
qualifying the multiplier they did not
change that number so um then as Melissa
stated there would be more um cost for
the the local level on that with the the
lower um
percentage and I think right now they're
looking at upping the percentage because
when they dropped it to 25 I think the
current administration's looking at to
upping that back to I think they were
saying 60% yes
so you know was the intent do you know
what the intent of the program
was I I believe just as as you stated to
to lessen the burden of filling out the
applications um because once you're on
this program you'd be on it for five
years so you'd have that um identified
percentage for five years there is the
capability that you could reapply every
single year and then you would start
your five years over again um but the
intent of the program was you know just
that to limit the the burden of you know
the applications and then to be able to
provide um meals at no cost to the to
the student thank you that
helps um and then the last page um again
is just for your reference on the the
poverty um guidelines that we are um
currently using for for reference
representative muray uh yeah just
curious can you define how they define
Household here because I see it goes up
to 14 uh which a whole lot of kids but
is there you know a household um a
legitimate defined household in terms of
grandparents or in-laws or auns and
uncles or you know can you
justify I would need to get that
information for
you now it's a good
question yeah one other thing um there's
a lot less well maybe not a lot there
seems to be less paperwork on your
shoulders now than there used to be that
some of that has been
streamlined are you is there a way or do
you what would you like to see happen in
terms of making it easier for you to
identify these children and doing you
know doing right by these kids in terms
of all the paperwork and stuff you have
to do well I think that the feds the
federal programs require an application
to be filled out so we're we're all
required to provide a paper applications
so that that part of it cannot change um
and then the switching to you know you
can offer an online application but
again that's a cost at the local level
to have to develop those online
applications so um I think that when
that's a cost that has to be Cur at
incurred at the local level that's got
to be a local level Det determination
Wester whether they want to pursue that
or not so there's not a lot we could do
to help you there sounds like I think
that would be more of a question maybe
for that for the local
level thank
you thank
you question
before go ahead just a quick question
Melissa could you repeat your last name
we couldn't I didn't write it down fast
enough I apolog I'm sorry Melissa white
thank you so
much thank you and what's the other ones
Rand should know her name I recognize
her instruction
Rambo how do you spell
Rambo oh good for you everybody else
that up
here okay please introduce yourselves
and carry on uh just want to cover a
topic that um members that have been
division 2 for uh have heard these
conversations before um as you know the
nutrition program is a program about
reimbursing for meals and it's about the
nutrition aspect of it you also know
members have been on this committee f&r
data impacts adequacy funding and so
anytime you dive into that policy area
and you're impacting potentially
applications or fnr student counts in
any way you're going to impact the
adequacy side of it so um uh if you have
any sort of uh the only thing I can sort
of advise you on is think about how any
program policy changes you make might
impact our ability to count either under
count or uh not overcount but um uh
potentially count those fnr students so
um local policy makers also make those
decisions they think about potentially
offering um Universal meals um and then
we have to remind them that you might
have a hard time getting them to fill
out the form if you've already agreed to
pay for it without a form so that's a
local decision that local districts make
and some of them look at the adequacy
numbers and they look at the the they
crunch the numbers and it would be
better for them to get them to fill out
the form so they can get more adequacy
funding um so those are local polic
policy decisions that locals make um you
also as a from the state level need to
or need to keep that in mind as you as
you look at this area that it impacts
adequacy so just wanted to remind you of
that any questions on
that thank
you and I can answer I think there were
couple of questions that came up
regarding uh Career and Technical
education programs um they decided they
separ oh okay that sounds good yeah we
decid sorry I that we decided that on
Monday that we'll actually have Jeff
come and do a like full presentation
sounds seem like they have a lot of
questions perfect there was one followup
question I and that was the question I
was um available to answer so um I think
there was a question regarding how much
goes to the community college system of
the federal Perkins funds so the
department of education our allocation
comes in at about just under 7 million
so we've get about 6.9 million to um
administer the through Perkins to
administer our Career and Technical
education programs and of that about 1.2
million goes to the Community College
systems the Community College systems
then divides that up could you could you
back up sure so first of all you started
talking about what was the name of the
program the Career and Technical
education I got that part okay the other
name you use Perkins and what is a
Federal grant program that's just the
name of the act that provides the funds
to all
states for that program and what is that
program about for what purpose it's for
um developing Career and Technical
education programs in in the US okay so
not not portion of that so we get about
6.9
million just under 7 million to
administer that
program of those funds about 1.2 million
is then distributed to the community
college
system and the community college system
then takes that 1.2 million and they
divide it among their seven uh community
college system colleges and I think the
amount when we went in and did an
analysis is given to each of those seven
is about equal and it covers um the pel
grants recipients so
so there questions those are the pel
grants yes or it goes to the pel grant
recipients so on top of their pel grants
um it might be part of it I'm not
exactly sure I think that'd be a
question for the community it's on top
of okay on top of it okay and what what
happens to the other 5.7 million of that
Perkins thing so there's a a small
percentage that goes for administration
of the funds there's a small percentage
that's for set aside for State programs
that we might initiate at the state
level and then then we have um the rest
that goes out to the
schools to the public schools yes
correct just distributed to oh no not to
the public schools it goes to our
regional Career and Technical Education
Centers to the Regionals yes
okay so at a later date we'll have Jeff
beard and who's the administrator of the
special education program and he will
bring the town Bytown allocations um
he'll talk about the state career and
Tech education funding program as well
as the um
um the capital project programs that are
for career and tech ed so that's we just
didn't think we had room to do it today
because it's a pretty big topic so
career and tech ed is basically High
School yes and it's some a little bit at
the college level as well the community
college
level well I get that but when you say
that 1.2 million goes to ccsnh you're
treating that part is in up separate
correct the part that you said the
remainder is basically High School
correct yes or no yes well it it stems
through you can use some of the funds to
Target Middle School participation to
increase so I mean it can be used middle
to high school and we do maybe a little
bit of to promote the education at the
middle school level but yes you're high
school it is High School Middle sign I
can work with middle but not high school
okay thank
you here we on
all right we're going to switch topics
we're going to do state special
education
funding um so I'm Caitlyn I was here the
other day um I will be discussing the
model and the formula aspects of this
but if you have questions specific to
special education programming um Melissa
is going to provide that support to the
committee she oversees the instructional
portion of the program um and some of
the formula distribution and then I work
on the data and the funding side of it
with my team so it's a kind of a split
project between the the two divisions um
so for those of you that um were at the
Department of Education orientation day
a few weeks ago you'll remember um
Rebecca fet who's the state
administrator of the special education
Bureau went through um how special
education in the seity of New Hampshire
works the different you know the
different types of programming the
approvals for the special education um
schools and she talked about you know
the different Revenue sources with this
the state federal um and other Federal
sources there is one state special
education program um specifically
special education funding program that's
in the education trust fund that has
been in the newspapers quite a bit
lately um because it uh there was a
shortfall in funding in the state budget
this year so that's the part we're going
to talk about today so it's called state
educ state special education funding um
it was previously known as catastrophic
Aid um those of us who've been doing
this for a long time have a tough time
not calling it that still so if you ever
hear me call CAD Aid this is what I'm
referring to um it was previously
General funded um however two budget
sessions ago I believe it was moved into
the education trust fund um I think by
this committee um and that's where it's
remained um so the way it works is the
Department of Education determine it
appropriation in our budget remember
typically when the Department of
Education is doing a budget we two years
out from the budget act actually
happening so the budget that you're
working in 26 the most recent
information that we had was school year
23's information so we're working a
couple years behind so a lot of people
are asking us kind of how that shortfall
ended up happening in this year's budget
well when and I'll go through this it's
in the packet but when we were working
on the budget two years ago that was the
number that we felt would be sufficient
to fully fund this uh
obligation so in your packet if you want
to go to one the pages labeled three out
of six I do have a visual but I'm going
to actually talk about and you can
ignore the visual if you're more of a
visual person but I'm going to talk
about the cost allocation sample so the
way this
funding which document are you looking
at H the one that says cost
allocation one that is a different
document oh oh
wait yeah that one it's showing up
online it's just the front page on oh
okay well no online Mickey
well I don't do you yeah do you have
another copy
Mickey yeah maybe we just sent him the
one page yeah do you have a copy of it
no I don't okay well we have extra
copies thank you there's more over there
too M sorry about that that's okay it's
the downside of having a computer I
guess we're trying you're doing great
you're doing great all right so there's
a formula the formula is in state law
it's rsa1 86c um it's embedded in the in
total special education law in New
Hampshire um and the funding formula is
to help support local public school
districts with costs associated with
children that are high cost meaning
higher than three and a half times the
average cost per pupil in the state of
New Hampshire um so that the three and a
half times the average three and a half
times is determined by the office of
school finance and we publish that
number we do an estimate for the purpose
of um this formula and then we provide
that information to schools and schools
then go throughout a year and C up the
costs associated with a child and if a
child may have costs that exceed that
three and a half times amount at the end
of the school year they submit to the
Department of Education for
reimbursement through this formula um so
what happens is it's a pretty manual
process but we have a team of people in
the Bureau of special education who take
in all of the invoices associated with
these children's IEPs the individual
education program program or plan
program program um IND education program
and then um we look at all of the
invoices we ensure that the invoices
support it support various different
services that are needed to be required
as part of the IEP and that it's all
allowable and and appropriate for the
kids disability as determined by the
local school district and then we
determine amount of those inv ches
that's allowable to figure out what the
Department of Education might
potentially owe for that kid so once
we've done that that that's kind of big
part part of the work so we assume let's
for the example that's on the left side
of so we assume that the kids allowable
costs are
$150,000 so they might have additional
costs but they may have not been
allowable or for whatever reason um just
not included so the $150,000 of
allowable costs 3 and half times the
average cost per pupil last year was
69,6 so if you look down here so the
first thing that we do is the
69,6 that is the school district's
liability for the school district so
they have to cover everything up to
three and a half times after three and a
half times the formula that's in state
law says that the state will pay 80% of
the amount above three and a half
times and then um so the we what we do
so we take all of the kids we figure out
all that 80% for the entire State and we
add it up and we figure out what the
total amount that we would need to pay
is and then we figure out what we have
for appropriation and we then will'll
prate it as needed so um there's a lot
of confusion a lot of times around this
that the 80% of the pration just becomes
or sorry the 80% just becomes a lower
amount but we're actually paying 80 or
sorry this year it was 60% so 68% so we
pay 68% of the 80% of the cap of the
amount that exceed the cap so you can
kind of see here the way the spreadsheet
works is so the total District
entitlement from the state of New
Hampshire for this $150,000 kid at the
top was
$64,000 um and the state of New
Hampshire's um amount was
$44,000 so the total amount for the kid
is the state paid $44,000 and the state
paid $150,000 for the
kid so that's a kid that is just regular
um
between so there's there's once you get
over 3 and half% it's fixed is not
another there's not another break point
there is another break point um that's
with the second example that you have on
your page um but just need to make sure
you understand the first one first
because it gets a little bit more
complicated so once you get over the 80%
or sorry once you hit over the three and
a half times and they get up to 10 times
then you're eligible for 100% of those
costs that exceed 10 times so the
example on the second part of your page
is a student that's cost $300,000 or had
expenses of
$300,000 so the first part of that we do
is the three and a half times or sorry
the three and a half times is the
$70,000 so we take that $70,000 out and
then the amount from 3 and 1/2 to 10
times is 80% reimbursable and the amount
that exceeds 10 times is 100%
reimbursable from the state then that
total amount is then PR rated and these
are the areas that there's a lot of
confusion because people kind of over
the years think that oh well then this's
paying 100% of that and 80% of that
which then you know the 80% is decreased
to the 60% and we're still paying 100%
but no what we do is we figure out the
total States required amount for that
kid and then prate that amount in total
so um and I do want to kind of point out
this is State special education funding
like this line item that's in the state
budget only there are some other special
education funding um that could come
into play here that school districts are
receiving for kids but not child
specific funding to help with these
specific costs so remember there was I
think it's like 67 million in adequacy
that's differentiated aid for adequacy
that's different from this there's also
Federal DEA formula funds um that school
districts receive and then some of these
uh kids are Medicaid eligible as well so
school school districts have a program
that they access through HHS called
Medicaid to schools and can re get
reimbursement for some of this but for
this alone this is the way this formula
works so the next page that's in your
packet rep ha and Phillips um I'm just a
little con uh confused about how the
pration works um all the other
explanation made complete sense to me
I'm just a little caught up about
um maybe you just walk through if you
could like the process of creating like
determining what the pration is maybe
that will make so actually the next page
is we can to help you do that so the
next page is the history of uh State
special education cadid um so we have
back you can see going back to 2007 um
we have the data this this program has
actually been around for a very long
time this is the slide that we have that
we've been using it so it's 200 7 so the
very first line it says paid in January
25 so that's the money we just paid
related to last school year so it's
always it's again like adequacy it's
paid in one year in a rares because the
school districts have to go through the
complete costs of a kid send it to us
over the summer we do that review I
mentioned um and so the total of all of
the kids submitted the total allowable
cost submitted to the Department of
Education this year was 1119 million so
those are the allow able cost so on the
on the last page we talked about the two
the 150 and the 300 bucket that's that
now once the department of education's
done its review it's taken the cap and
it's taken the 80% and anything that out
it comes down to 49 million so 49 is the
amount the state in theory would have to
pay if there was not a pration provision
but because when I T started out I said
remember we worked on these numbers
several years ago so when we were in the
summer of
22 we had when we were working on the
last state budget we had um that January
22 payment we had just made we said all
right well our appropriation was $31
million it was sufficient to make our
entire payment we said all right well
let's use 33 for 24 and 25 because that
seems like it should be sufficient based
on the way that history has um kind of
come out as far as the funding and so we
use that number for our budget and then
here we are in 25 where we had school
districts request $49 million and only
we only had $33 million of appropriation
and so that's how we come up with that
pration amount and you can see the
historical Trends over the years so um
this year 69% last year 87% 98% 100 and
100 um and you can see you know the
funds were relatively high they were
around $30 million back in 20072 2008 um
and then there were some pretty big cuts
around the big financial crisis in the
mid 2000s and the funding has been
appropriated at higher amounts over the
last several years um but we are still
in an area again what we will be we are
prating the payment
so go ahead thanks um I'm just wondering
what does this mean in practicality for
in terms of the local District's budget
planning process so um do you identify
the proportion of the pration amount in
real time so that they can plan their
budget process or does that number get
released after the budgets are set so
it's released after the budgets are set
because the budgets are set in the
previous year right um but it is
um yeah so we give them an estimate on
October 1st um of all the different
state revenues and so we have the
different state revenues we tell them
what adequacy is going to be and what we
anticipate this amount would be um and
they use that going
forward represent papovich thank you Mr
chair and again thank you for taking
questions um you were talking about how
you forecast the amount and uh this
seems to be a significant increase and
not necessarily following the past
Trends does the department get any
insight into what caused this
significant increase in special
education costs
oh thank you for the question so it I
mean it definitely fluctuates throughout
the year so you can see like you know
we're coming in PID January of 2010
we're looking at 95 million I mean it
the there's fluctuations throughout it
goes down it goes up um I think there's
also
um you know some questions about whether
the pandemic the increase in just cost
in general for all things I mean if we
look at groceries everything has gone up
um I mean that could definitely come
into play but as you can see I mean the
numbers of students or the student count
that that's gone up it's gone down so
it's really difficult to determine if
it's you know the services that have
gone up that are more costly if it's
just a
fluctuation follow up yeah just go on
thank you I appreciate it and I know
it's tough because you only have so much
data so the other question I'm sure
you've heard it from me the past but not
in this
committee when you determine that you
know a funding uh invoice is uh you know
approved by you guys you are just
looking at the nature of the service and
in whether it's appropriate for the kid
or do you also consider whether the cost
charge for that particular invoice is
reasonable in view of you know State
costs or whatever other benchmarks you
may have we do not evaluate that part of
it but we do look to see if the services
are in the students IEP so if they're
billing us for services that are not in
the students IEP those would not be an
allowable cost so we go and look at the
students IEP if the services are in the
IEP then they can um submit invoices on
um behalf of that I think it's also
worth mentioning that the co relief
funds there was a significant amount of
coming of funding coming into the
schools with Co relief funds special
education also received a separate
allocation and so idea there was a
portion carved out of the elementary and
secondary education Relief act that
provided funds specifically for students
with disabilities and so what we're
seeing is that last year was kind of a a
not not a cliff but a little bit of that
so that they had a lot of funding to
maybe support some of those more acute
issues and then that funding did go down
because the funds
ended one one additional thing so many
of these kids are in and out of District
placement mean they're not receiving
their services specifically speically in
their school district if they're in a
New Hampshire nonpublic school um that
has been approved for providing special
education services we do have a rate
setting process so those schools can't
charge more than those rates being
allowed by the Department of Education
but the Department of Education doesn't
have rate setting in the same way that
Medicaid might HHS for specific OT
services that a school district can
charge thank you and I'm assuming that
you have the same limitations when you
deal with kids placed out of state that
we have no real authority over out of
state placements so it is what it is and
the last question on this
topic I know that it's very hard to
compare apples with apples when you talk
about special education services because
every kid's needs are very different but
I'm sure in certain categories you may
be able to just look at the broad range
of prices charged across the state for
what appear to be similar services do
you guys have the authority or the
resources needed to look at that to
determine whether you know we may have a
need to uh verify that charges are
reasonable thank you for the question I
do really appreciate that the state
contributes a very small amount to the
Department of Education to to for our
administrative costs and so if you look
at special education most of our
administrative costs are covered by Ida
the federal funding so I am able to pay
for 25% of a position so 0.25 of an te
for special education and then I able to
have some temporary positions to do the
special education Aid invoice review so
I bring in temporary staff to come in
and do the processing of the invoices
because I don't have the ability to fund
staff to do that so I would say that
what the state actually contributes to
special
education um Administration there there
is a disparity there because we don't
have the resources to be able to go in
and do a lot of of the data analysis I
don't have the staff to go in and do
invoice analysis all of the staff that I
do have for special education has to be
deployed to meeting the federal
requirements Federal data going in and
doing those type of monitoring process
so it does make it a little bit
difficult to bring somebody in to do
that that level of detail I appreciate
the question repres Murray thank you I'm
not sure if I'm thinking of the right
program but last year we had a lot of
discussion and I think the bill passed
about different levels of need so there
was you know um someone the lisp as
opposed to someone who's a quadriplegic
and the different so do you know what
I'm what I'm referring to and does that
pertain to this or is that am I
confusing with another program it didn't
get through the Senate no it didn't and
it makes it a bit difficult because if
the state is to then base funding on
levels of students disabilities or
determinations we have to undergo a
pretty a pretty significant monitoring
of that system and we'd have to bring in
additional staff just to be able to do
that so the federal program if they see
States enacting that type of legislation
then they come in and say okay you've
got to go in and do double duty
analyzing and going in and monitoring to
make sure that those students are not
Mis appropriately being identified to
then qualify for some of those those
funding sources so it's actually better
for you that it did not
pass I I take uh I I stay neutral on
that thank you I appreciate the question
though two questions related to what you
were discussing with representative
papovich
so Staffing if you had more staff you
could do a better job of determination
which actually might impact the costs or
maybe quality of staff that could then
you know a position that could a datea
an analyst that could go in and maybe
look a little bit more closely and do a
deeper dive into the types of of
services and maybe
also cross referencing that with other
states even states around us to look at
those Services when we look at placing a
student a New Hampshire student in an
out of distri placement out of state
that's where costs can tend to be
compounded so you know being you know I
can take a look at that but I need to
have somebody to be able to go in and
maybe do a deeper dive so given that
we're trying to reduce or eliminate
those just go back to the the non out
ofate placements could you have an
impact that actually might
reduce the costs or would it just give
us analysis of where the costs are
occurring I think it would give us the
both maybe being able to look at you
know where those costs are maybe
comparison of what it looks like in
State versus out of state um maybe
across the state maybe we're looking at
rule I I mean I could think of a many
variables like maybe rule services are a
little bit more but I I can't give you
anything concrete because we don't have
the data is that like a person or like a
couple I mean how many when you say you
need people how many people would you
need I mean it could be done in a
variety of ways we could look at people
but we could also look at Contracting
the services out
how much money would you need you don't
need to give me an answer but maybe you
think about that thank you um and the
other side of things um regarding it
sounds like you don't hear any of this
news until after the school year closes
and then oh here they all are as opposed
to somebody recognizing that we've hit
75 what whatever the magic number is you
know in U October and uh basically let
giving you a heads up that across the
state that things are starting to happen
um before you get to you know June 30th
or whatever so I was the way the
legislation is written we just have to
follow it the timeline that it's laid
out so it is so this is I mean this is
actually something that I was asked
recently too and I think the difficulty
with this program is we are only talking
about 800 kids across the state so a
district might have one kid or two kids
that they haven't had in the past or no
kids but it's not necessarily something
that we're seeing you know 30 40 50%
increase across the state because even
though this is a a lot of money it
spread across the entire State there is
really no kind of red flags that were
going off on you know any Flags but now
does maybe one or two District say well
I think my special education costs are
higher than normal that potentially
could have been a conversation that's
had but it's not been something that's
been brought to the
department okay I think you
misunderstood my question so I'm
thinking of per student because this is
all per student right everything here so
if the district is tracking this per
student spending m MH they can they know
when it's going to hit that first
threshold whatever that was and right at
that point they could let you know oh we
have a student that's this is going to
be a student that's there going to be an
issue at at some level and could be
giving you tracking information from
that point forward and especially what
happened in October you could start
getting you start have an idea that
across the state now you're all doing
this I mean these things just don't all
pop up on last day of June these
expenses I mean I would
say that
perhaps the tracking it really does not
become apparent for many of them until
more towards the end of the
year that's a problem so well two things
before I forget you mentioned
legislation affects something so please
let me know what that legislation is so
I can understand what that is so if it
needs to be undone we can undo it um you
I think you indicated that with regard
to this tracking stuff um in terms of
timing but but but to the issue if our
local districts are waiting until the
end of June and now going okay we got
one or two kids whatever let's you know
we all pieces of
paper that's bad accounting I mean they
should be accounting for this through
the entire year wouldn't you well I
won't ask if you agree that's an opinion
that'd be my opinion so um might it make
a difference if you saw what this was
coming sooner so depending on what your
scheduling is looking like for D2
because we know March gets very busy
very quickly but when we're looking at
some of these programs especially if
you're considering making a decision
that might impact the funding I would
recommend that we have one or two
business administrators or special
education administrators from a school
district to kind of come in and talk
about this um those of you that were on
D2 last time know there was a lot of
conversations about building Aid and so
we did have some build some business
administrators from schools come in so I
think that might help the committee um
understand how this is implemented
locally and help your decision-making
process and we can facilitate that but
it's just you know will you have the
time to do that is that's a question
okay well Mick will put that down and
did you say business administrators I
hope not special education no business
administrators and special education
administrators it varies it does vary by
school who kind of has this function
sometimes it's much more on the special
education side of things some times it's
much so it depends on skill set and
school district and resources and
whatnot so we but we can we can
determine that on our side of things and
I will say some of the the the programs
that submit invoices and some of the
providers that are submitting invoices I
mean they're not always timely either so
it's not as if it's completely the
responsibility and I think that's a good
suggestion to bring in some business
administrators to give some perspective
because sometimes we do see even for
some of our court order placements and
episodes of treatment they they're
submitting their billing maybe not on a
timely manner as well so it it it gets
compounded because it's a process where
the invoices go from the provider to the
district the district then pays it and
because it's all on a reimbursement
basis then we're going back and and
doing the review I do understand those
kind of lags but if they're not filing
at least quarterly you might just say
you're not going to get paid um there's
a lot of things you can do to solve that
problem representing papovich I think
well just to your point so there's
another program there's another program
that it's called 402 court ordered
placements and they do file quarterly on
that actually up to monthly but because
of the nature of that program so that n
that program is paid in full no matter
what so as soon as they can start
getting the revenue flowing they do they
start submitting those invoices but
because this program has to be prated
across the entire State all of the
schools submit everything at one time
because we can't we have to have 100% of
everything processed before we can
determine what district is um eligible
for what funds so totally understand
that um I guess the way I'm looking at
this is if you had an
idea say in January or February that
there's going to be an issue just keep
in mind especially the second year of
the budget if we happen to have good
years like we have had in the past we
could say oh we need to well I do also
want to remind you what Melissa had just
said is that she has part-time seasonal
employees that do this work so those
people are not at the Department of
Education in January or February they
come in in August to start doing this
that's why I ask about the Staffing as
well this is It's a complicated process
and I think it's good we're having these
conversations okay re po thank you and
uh basically my question is just to wrap
up this uh
conversation in an Ideal World if the
schools were able to feed you this data
through the year you know once somebody
reaches the threshold they start telling
you hey we are getting there would that
make a difference to you in terms of
being able to address the funding or you
would just see the big boulder coming
earlier but still be in the
way I
mean we could certainly if we had more
realtime reporting keep the legislature
more updated on it um that would that's
something I think just that alone would
would go a long way um but as far as
addressing you know are the costs too
high we would need I think additional
authorities and and whatnot understood
but I was just thinking right now about
that 68% that we are at because I don't
think the legislature is uh you know
excited about that low percentage right
and we understand the nature of the
forecast and the unusual spike in cause
that made this happen right but the
question was really if if we would see
this coming earlier would that give us
more time between the Department of
Education and the legislature or fiscal
or wherever else where we may need to
maybe address this rather than you know
find about it months later after
everybody's rates are set and create a
lot of uncertainty in the process and I
think the answer is possibly yes right
but it's not a definite answer right now
yeah I think ABS I think what you're
saying is yes absolutely we just need to
think about how the system would work to
do that it's complicated nobody's saying
it's a flip a switch thank
you Kelly thank you may maybe you've
already explained this because I'm
trying to process all this information
um your last column probation amount it
really fluctuates a lot is that part of
yes the probation amount is really just
dependent on um what is appropriated
versus what the total expenses that come
in it so um and I I want to remind you
all in this room is we're very
frequently told to do level funded
budgets which means all right well we
had 33 million last year and that was
sufficient we're going to put $33
million in this year so Department kind
of sticks to the mentality the
legislature has been relatively generous
as far as this account and appropriating
additional funds in this account over
the the last several years but clearly
the expenses have increased faster than
we
anticipated thank
you just to remind the committee unlike
adequacy charter schools and uh efas
there's no open warrant for special
education funding there's no mechanism
for the Department to draw a warrant to
pay that difference they can't come to
fiscal committee for additional funds to
pay that difference so it would require
legislation if you wanted to do anything
for a fiscal 25 for instance I well
understand all of that well the first
the first place you have to start though
is getting the
data but I but I do understand that
would require fiscal or something to be
allowed to handle it well what I'm
saying is fiscal can't under current law
current law right but we got to and
there are bills I'll just remind there
are bills mostly in the Ed funding
committee right now that deal with this
one that I think eliminates the pration
entirely one that sets it that it can
never go lower than 85% and should any
of those pass they would be referred
here and it could be something we
incorporate in in your budget package
right and keep in mind the Senate can do
anything uh okay they can put a bill in
in middle of whenever and allocate money
for whatever so the question is is the
information there that would allow us to
take the next step which is to try to
rectify the situation and get ahead of
it that's all I'm
asking but thank you I appreciate your
responses and I don't fault the
education w at all for the budgeting
that's not my that's that's not my point
at all it's just a question of can we
track things better and have have an
idea we're going to we're going to run
into an issue um before June represent
of
Dy just
curious do you trend
the special ed um I the um when they you
know I'm sorry I lost my trainer thought
here but a student has an IEP and it's
all these different things do the
schools or you Trend all of these issues
that the students are
having that we have to appropriate for
does that make sense to you that
question Pur well it you wouldn't
necessarily have their name but every
student that has a slew of IEPs for
whatever reason they are I mean is there
any kind of trending that is done on
that that we can see that there's a
certain problem that's happening it
seems to be more
consistent do you do you understand what
I'm saying I I'm not entirely sure if
you're talking about per disability like
if we're looking at a like a cost of
that or if we're looking at I I I think
the that it would be challenging to do
that piece of it um I get I'm probably
talking more about because we have a lot
of students it's growing the
disabilities are growing so we know
something's happening right okay and
then we have to appropriate funds for
each one of
these issues somebody has to deal with
maybe reading or mathematical or
whatever it might be and then wellness
and and all these things that we're
paying for is that correct this the
various different disabilities aren't
appropriated separately no um no so the
way it works is we have a base amount
that's in adequacy that every single kid
that has an IEP is is entitled to
receive all the school district is
entitled to receive for that kid and
then there's some federal funds and
whatnot and then when you have a child
that is high cost because the IEP just
is a essentially a schedule of services
it describes a child's disability an
educational plan to get the child um to
help with the children's and then
services that are needed for that child
doesn't have any of that cost
information it it doesn't say this
kiding OT and it's going to cost $50,000
or something like that until a school
district knows that child has high costs
usually the kid has pretty severe
disabilities to meet this three and a
half times and then that's when they
start saying like all right well let's
find all of the invoices associated with
Caitlyn Davis and submit those to the
Department of Education because we think
they're going to be eligible for this um
pool of funds but we have 30,000 kids in
the state of New Hampshire that are have
an IEP and we're talking about less than
a thousand of those kids so a very small
percentage of those kids we're talking
about in total for this okay that
explains it thank
you carry on was there somebody else
that's it for special ed then we're
going to switch topics okay all
right and C can somebody eventually
okay or do we not have any extras of
those good they are there any exes of
those do we have any extra building Aid
ones Micky or do we pass them all out
oh oh
thanks yeah I got one thanks Jim this
and you put everybody all in the same
place or this is all three oh
okay perfect
thanks um all right so next upep we're
going to switch over to the Bureau of
school facilities um again this is one
that is in uh my area of expertise uh
Tim Carney is our new administrator of
the bureau he's three weeks on the job
now yeah about three weeks um so his
first day was presenting to you guys at
the Department of Education so that was
pretty impressive that he was able to do
that he's learned a little bit more a
little bit more um but so I'm going to
let him take the reins but we'll deal
with questions as they come great well
thank you Caitlyn so again uh Tim Carney
Bureau administrator for the uh Bureau
of school
facilities and we have three packets
today three programs uh School building
Aid Charter School lease Aid and then
what we refer to as say uh the safe
Grant security action for Education
grants so if we I can start with the
school building Aid packet we should all
have that um we'll go Page by page if
that's okay uh so again the first page
just a summary um of what we're going to
be going through uh contact information
I did update this slightly from the
packet that you received back in
January uh one so my contact information
wasn't three hole punched out um
and so the school building aid program
it it allows uh provide State funds for
school districts uh in support of
meeting the costs of uh constructing
renovating replacing school facilities
um the grants range from 30 to 60% of
the cost of the eligible cost of
construction uh and we'll get into that
um across the state um so we have 30% is
for more affluent communities 60% for
Less affluent communities the average
across the state in the last number of
years um before the the
um um moratorium it was about
38% uh the funding source is the
education trust fund and there was a lot
of change in
2013 so from it's a very old program
1946 uh the state paid a percentage of
the principle over the life of a bond so
if it's School District took out a
20year bond every year the state would
pay between 30 and 60% of that Bond
payment um that law was changed in
2013 and now it's more we pay current
costs and so right now we're paying 80%
Upfront for a school that gets awarded
building Aid so it's 80% of that 60 to
30% and then upon completion of the
project and some uh auditing and uh data
submission to our office for
verification uh we will award up to the
remaining
20% uh so that's I have an example for
how we used to do it and how we do it
currently um the 2013 law also capped
the amount of school building Aid
appropriated to no more than 50 million
per year and it also created a
competitive Grant structure uh that we
go through a ranking process for these
projects um the former way we did
between 46 and
2012 virtually every school that came
forward with a qualifying project was
awarded
funding um so the the uh schools are
ranked higher if they address project uh
life safety issues Ada deficiency
overcrowding consolidation and in the
law these different components of the
application have different points and
that's how the ranking is done by a team
um in myself and we bring in Engineers
to assist us with that um to do a
ranking of all the projects we receive
uh this coming April and that's when the
applications are due for new projects um
will be the first cohort that's done
under this new set of rules and so that
will be an interesting uh bit of work to
see how what we run into as far as
unintended consequences sometimes when
you implement these types of new rules
uh uh I won't go through the the
detailed building Aid funding history
but you will see between 2010 and 2017
there was a moratorium complete
moratorium on projects um and then there
was a couple projects
1819 um that one emergency funded
project uh 2020 and 21 the moratorium
was lifted again we had a competitive
project application process I was
involved with that with Amy Clark my
predecessor as one of the folks who was
um invited on the ranking team just
because of my background um and then uh
in 2022 23 12 applications received only
two projects were funded and then
2425 uh again competitive process 17
applications were received uh three
applications were selected for
funding we want to flip over to the
second page again just a quick
uh table on the history I won't get into
a lot of detail on this but it it a lot
of what I just talked about is summarize
here in visual format um and you can see
46 to
2009 um there were 62 applications
funded and I think that was um again my
predecessor created this one so I'm not
sure if that's a total or if that's more
of an average for that
period yes it's average by any okay yes
so bium average so 62 per bium again
that's when schools if they had a
acceptable application they were awarded
funding so it wasn't a competitive
process
then do want to point out too it's
allowable costs so not everything a
school is building is allowable and we
actually when we'll talk about the
examples we can we can kind of give you
we can show about that lat later on in
packet sure thank you so we want to flip
the
page to the
School building aid funds graph um so
there's three components to the the
excuse me the each annual payment um
dark blue obligated payment sets from
what we call the tail those projects
before the
moratorium uh in 2010 there was a state
Bond uh taken out to make the annual
Bond payment um or maybe the banum at
that point um and so that's the light
blue
and then new projects or funding
available for new projects is the dashed
line and so in 24 we had 22.6 million
available for new projects and 25
similarly we had 26.1 million if the
project uh the the maximum is held at
$50 million we just look at 26 and 27 so
26 that would allow the department to
potentially award 28.9 million for new
projects those would be the projects
coming in April 1st of this year and
then 27 again 31.8
million any questions
on anything so far yes repr ha Phillips
um I think in the past when we've had
extensive conversations about this um
there's always been the question can we
pay our debt service earlier to try to
end the tale before for
2041 and I correct me if I'm wrong but
it's my understanding that there's not a
early like there is a prepayment penalty
so we can't work on those debt
payment in advance it that's kind of how
bonds work it's not like a mortgage
where you can pay them off early exactly
um so that's that's what the challenge
has been because these school districts
took out bonds so even if we gave the
funds to the schools um to pay it off
early there would be no way for the
schools to pay off their bond early and
schools can't just hang on to funds
so it definitely creates complicated
structure but yeah last year when there
was a lot of EXT excess money in the
education trust fund that was a
conversation that was
had one more uh so
um building on that conversation as well
has been a concern of whether or not the
50 million allocated in each budget
year is in a lapsing or a
non-aps um track and so I'm just
wondering if you could speak to that as
well so it it it lapses if there's
excess funds that does lapse it laps
back to the education trust fund so it's
not going back to the general fund in
the past it would have laed lapsed into
the general fund but because it's also
an education trust fund um there was a
proposal to have a specific building Aid
fund that we talked about in division
two last year um but that proposal
didn't make it I think it was came from
the governor's budget um and but it
didn't make it out of division
two represent papovich thank you not as
much a question but just adding a bit
more context to what my colleague was
asking
about um because the tail is just
reimbursing school districts individual
school districts for Bond payments that
they are obligated to the state could
even make them refinance if it wanted to
and also every school district has
negotiated specific terms on their bonds
now some of them may be payable early if
the school district had an inclination
to but then we don't have mechanism to
do that and some of them are non-p
payable early and it depends whether you
went directly to the banks or you went
through the uh you know it basically
becomes so complicated that I think at
the state level based on the benefits
that we would get it would probably not
be the best way for us to spend
legislative time because it would be a
very minimal return
so great thank you uh turning to the
next page so we we have school building
Aid factors and this is just some more
detailed information um so this is uh we
calculate our school building Aid
factors and that leads us into what the
the aid rates are the 30 to 60% I
mentioned earlier um we do you know if
you look at the the note toward the
bottom it does say that these building
Aid factors are function of
municipalities medium family income and
the equalized value per pupil so it does
take some of that poverty or affluence
into effect um so that's some detail
there and
then two pages of that so that's on the
second page as
well and then if you want to take a look
at the the following page that's the
school building Aid descending rank
order list and so this is the current
list that we're working off of that was
approved by the school building
authority and then the state published
by the State Board of
Education um and there were 17
applications received those were all
ranked and we had um three that were
able in the process to accept the
funding and move forward with their
projects and that was uh so number one
uh out of Rochester number three which
is group of projects out of madok and
then all the way down to number 10 uh
which is Barnstead and so you know when
we go through the rankings and we let
schools know a lot of times they're
disappointed if they're further down the
list but it really shows that you know
what what happens at the local level
really impacts um you know their ability
to pass their bond or portion funding
portion of the the project um really
impacts what happens below so again
Barnstead initially was very
disappointed uh but working through the
process they ended up getting funding
for their project and they're they're
breaking ground in the middle of June
now um and so you know we do let
potential applicants know
that you're not necessarily out of the
running if you're not number one or
number
two just one other thing I want to point
out on this slide as well is so before I
was talking about the allowable cost so
if you look at the Nancy School Nancy
loud School in Rochester so Rochester is
a 60% Community you can see that their
estimated project cost is $33 million so
60% of $33 million is 20 million but you
can see the maximum building Aid award
is only 15 15 million that's because
they had costs in their total project
that wouldn't necessarily be allowed
under building Aid now I don't know off
the top of my head what they
specifically were but some of those
things may include you know construction
there's a cap on construction cost per
square foot um there's certain types of
um I can't even think of examples but
there are things that are not allowable
that the state will not reimburse and so
a school may need to cover more expenses
to do the complete project um or if they
have something that is um
much more robust and design than the
state will pay for the state won't kind
of take those extra costs in and that's
that's coming up relative to at least
one of the projects on this list if you
kind of look down through the list
you're like well that's a very high paid
project well not all of that is
allowable through the state so it's not
60% of the total project it's 60% of the
allowable costs and that's that's
important and to recognize because there
in Rochester for example there was a lot
of confusion about that we talked about
it in the Senate phase of the budget
because the chair of Senate Finance is
from Rochester and so it came up quite a
bit uh but that's that's just important
for the committee to know as we were
talking through this representative
hafeld Oh I thought you thank you we
were just wrestling about who should go
first um let your arm wrestle first
represented phps um could you please uh
walk us through what happens when a
community for instance like C Brook was
number two on this list um you know is
notified that they they're
they've received this ranking and um a
project is El to be paid out and they go
back to their town and hold their you
know meeting to decide whether or not
they're going to fund the bond and that
fails could you talk about what happens
next yeah and so I'm trying to get my uh
Amy provided me a nice little flowchart
that I will cheat off of um and so yeah
so what happens is once the ranking is
determined there's a letter of intent
sent to that district and the district
has the ability to either sign that or
say U we're not we don't want to
participate and then they they move to a
different pathway um as if they sign the
letter of intent they get um I believe
it's three opportunities to pass their
local vote and so it really depends on
I'm not familiar with what happen
specifically with colbrook if there if
it was at the letter of intent stage or
if it was one or two or three votes that
occurred before they came you know they
got passed over but that's my
understanding is the communities have
that opportunity over three budget
periods to to make that just a little
Nuance because the programs changed so
it's the timing of the program changed
they used to have to submit everything
to the Department of Education in the
summer and then it had to be ranked by
January which this committee typically
would have the ranked list when you were
making these decisions the timing was
changed applications need to be
submitted to the department by April y
year which means we don't have a rank
list for you I it was funny when we were
working on the program I think the
biggest challenge I thought was division
2 is going to be mad about this but
whatever um the legislators are writing
this law so they have to understand that
um but So Co Brook had two opportunities
to vote for the project just because of
the timing and so they received a letter
in intent and they had two opportunities
and um they were not able to get
anywhere I think they only received 30%
of their Town vote so nowhere yes to
nowhere close to the amount needed to
approve a bond so just as a followup so
what happens at the department after you
learn from a community that they're not
able to take advantage of the program
how do you move down your list like how
does that work I believe it's at the I
haven't been through this process but I
believe it's at the next cycle we repeat
that same process with it in first of
all may under the current rule um will
receive responses from the current uh
lists who aren't funded if they want to
stay on the list because some schools
are going to move forward right and so
based on that list we'll start that
process again where we'll issue the
letter of intent and see where they're
at one thing that's tricky about this
program too is that if you decide to
move forward with your project before
being awarded building Aid you are no
longer eligible for building Aid so that
means some people will wait and other
people will say I have to deal with this
there's no money available from the
state but this issue is so bad right now
that we have to do this or that a school
just say no this is a prior or District
sorry a community says this just a
community this is a priority for us
we're going to fund this with or without
the state um but yeah so with the
coldbrook money that's exactly what
happens to the C Brook money so we
actually had enough money for
essentially three projects that we knew
Rochester C Brook and madok we went
through we offered the money to
Rochester they said we were going to
take it we offered to C Brook they said
we'll take it we'll go to vote then we
offered to madok they said yep we'll
take it we'll go to vote um Rochester
and manano they voted they passed it co
Brooks failed the first time and then
went the second time failed again so
they let us know and so then that's when
we started moving down the list to all
of the other projects and we the first
group that said that we will take it was
Barnstead so yeah and I think another
Nuance of the program is that if you're
offered full funding of your project
under building Aid um and you deny it
then you you based on that letter of
intent before you go to vote then then
you're off the list but if you're only
awarded partial funding or offered
partial funding in deny it you can stay
on the list which makes sense because
many schools can't move forward with
their project unless they get the full
building Aid so they're elect not to
take partial and stay on the list and
back to your previous question so had
Barnstead not taken that money because
we were actually when we were going down
this like oh we might be lapsing some
building a money that $12 million would
have lapsed back to the education trust
fund
um if if Barnstead or somebody after
them had not decided to take those
funds representative
Murray yeah I think you pretty much um
went through all the questions I I
wanted to ask about if they can stay on
the list and not lose their ranking so
if co uh C Brook said yes
um but something had they would still be
able they're still on the list even
though when there was some some
discussion about you could Main maintain
your rating ranking if that's actually
one of the biggest changes about this
new program is is that you get to stay
on the list year after year so remember
submitting an application for building
Aid is very burdensome for a school
district there's a lot of costs
associated with an end time associated
with it and so um when the legislature
decided to change this a lot of that was
these schools that are submitting these
applications are spending all this time
and we don't have to want them to
reapply every single year but there was
no me mechanism for a school district to
not have to reapply and there was no
mechanism for a school district to
update the costs of their project so now
under the new program once you submit a
allowable project and we've approved it
and ranked it it stays on the list um
and at the time when you're going to
build your project that we've awarded
the money you're up you're allowed to
update your construction costs so um
with uh what is that means yeah RS means
the RS means standards so
so and I think another thing that to add
uh based on your ranking question is
that the remaining 14 of the 17 that are
ranked they will stay and applications
we get in April um there's one exception
for extraordinary circumstances but
other than that the new cohort of
applicants will come in below those
14 um and I think that's important to
understand and I think the last bit of
information is uh the the tail payments
more detail on those tail payments if
you wanted to uh dig into that
information um it shows what districts
and uh the projects and eligible costs
um and the payments for fiscal year 24
and
25 so do just one more Pro with building
Aid these are large scale Renovations or
building of new school schol these are
not for smaller projects this is you
know this is one of the questions that
comes up but can a school district
submit for building Aid if they want to
have a new HVAC system it's it's not for
that type of project it's for a wh scale
renovation new school maybe a wing of a
school if it's large enough but these
are not little
projects all
right repr hacka Phillips um Team I'm
wondering if you can um remind me this
was kind of the
the thing we were trying to sus out last
term about the
actual um you know estimated need over
time for the current like facility stock
we have in the state um you know if our
$50 million cap per year once we work on
The Debt Service and we're looking at a
17 school project list that we can only
fund three schools there's there's
clearly a need outside of the 50
million you you know cap so um I think
at one point last
term there was a discussion about you
know if we were if we were to try to
quantify what the need is year-over-year
to try to
eliminate having school projects that
don't get funded like these building
projects that don't get funded what
would that look like and I um I think we
were just talking what so I was part of
those conversations the resolution to
that was that you all wanted the
department of education to do a state
facilities assessment to to kind of
collect all of this information um which
we were which costs quite a bit of money
uh there's companies that do this other
states have gone through their process
and they'll they go through because we
don't have a comprehensive inventory of
school facilities in the state and I
know many people in the legislature
would want that um so there was a law
put in place and the funding was
actually also in that bill when we
talked about the um the school building
Aid fund that was an allowable use of
the school building fund um but
unfortunately that bill failed and then
there was a second bill to make it an
allowable use of the public school
infrastructure fund which we will talk
about in a moment that bill also failed
so the department hasn't made any
additional progress on that request
thank you for reminding me
representative Murray yeah thank you for
that U to remind us of that do you have
a sense of the cost of inflation between
a CA when the building is the proposal
is sent to you and the year and a half
or potentially two years before it is
built you know it's going to go up the
inflation has been somewhat more
significant uh now than it has been in
the past how do you account for that how
can schools plan for that so that's when
the schools are allowed to update their
application and specifically the
construction cost per square foot we
actually just had one so when we had
originally approved the project we
approved a construction cost per square
foot of 194 and I believe their actuals
came in around what 286 yeah 286 so they
um but that that is that school district
is from the time that they sent the
application was the 294 to the time the
project was completed so there's a
little um that's partially why this
project has or this program has evolved
to allowing them to update that on that
list and that hopefully accounts for it
now it's not going to necessarily
account for all of it and if changes
need to be made from the time the
project started to the time the project
ends through you know a change order
process which might have some
significant cost there's no additional
way for a school to account for
that great so should we move on to
Charter School Lee a yeah
okay so the uh the second program is
Charter School lease Aid and again you
have a packet for that similarly the the
first page is just a cover sheet with
some
information so Charter School lease a as
the name implies allows uh provides
lease assistance to charter schools that
are leasing the buildings rather than
owning them um grants are are 30% of the
annual lease payment and there's a cap
of $50,000 per
year um obviously like I mentioned
Charter School Charter Public Schools
that own their buildings are now
eligible and funding source education
trust fund and provide a brief history
of the uh lease Aid law and payments
that was the law was created in
2003 sorry um but it was only funded for
the first time in fiscal year
20 and uh again the data is there um
fiscal year the appropriation number of
charter schools requesting the aid It's
Not Unusual for CH some charter schools
to lease their building and then proceed
their
ownership um the amount eligible and
again because we do have a 30% percent
percentage and then a cap of
50,000 um if the appropriation does not
match the demand um that payment to each
each charter school is prated as you can
see in the second to last column um and
uh also there's a shortage shown there
as well um we do estimate there's going
to be an increase in the demand for
Charter School lease Aid not only due to
cost but also due to additional Charter
Schools coming coming
online and so uh part of the process
these completed applications are due to
the department on September 1st of each
year and um Carrie Gorman does a great
job with processing that information and
getting those payments
out um the next
page just again more detail uh list of
all the chartered schools at the time we
put this together for
25 um I believe there's a couple that
have been approved but not yet open
um so you'll see those next year and
again this just gives some more detail
um and again it's the far right column
uh you'll see we had this question
before so sometimes uh when obviously
when there's no lease it it means they
either did not apply or they own their
building so Academy of Science and
design for example owns their
building any questions
representative hack
Phillips I'm just wondering if there's
ever a case where uh lease a is
distributed to a
charter for um for like I guess my
question is is this Aid distributed with
a time lag or is it in real time and is
there a case where a charter may have
closed mid school year or you know midf
funding cycle so that some of that age
should be returned or does that not
happen so the schools that closed last
year specifically because those were the
ones that made the news um neither of
them received lease Aid um so but um if
a school were to receive lease Aid we
would make one payment at the beginning
of the year it is the amount in theory
for the full year and if they were to
close a right now there's no really
mechanism for a proportional amount of
that money to come back to the
department um both the schools that Clos
last year closed because of s
significant Financial issues um and at
least one of them ended up in bankruptcy
there were no assets or funds for the
Department to receive any funding back
um on that but it it is distributed once
a year so that is a risk of this
program all right one more topic for
today safe grants safe GRS you want to
do it I can do safe GR just didn't dive
into it oh sure sure so safe grants um
the security action for education grant
um is a subset of the public school
infrastructure fund so the public school
infrastructure fund was a fund that was
um I don't know invented by the
legislature in 2017 as part of the
budget cycle uh to allow initially for
smaller projects so maybe not building
Aid eligible projects but other project
project that schools may have for
schools to apply there were three uses
of the public school infrastructure
funds school safety grants e rates and
safety grants e- rates sorry e- rate um
my gosh uh like expansion of um like uh
like internet to schools and whatnot um
so e- rate expansion and then oh my gosh
oh oh so just oh small infrastructure
projects so like a HVAC or something
like that um these were actually part of
the conversations that were being had at
the time where conquered steam was
shutting down and conquered School
District was trying to seek additional
funds to um supplement the conversion
because of the conquered steam um and so
that was that was part of the
conversation when those funds were
originally um invented developed
whatever um so what had what the
legislation enabled was after the fiscal
year was closed from the state and after
the rainy day fund was topped off at 100
million or 200 million whatever the
amount was at there any excess General
funds would go into this fund called the
public school infrastructure fund and
become available for school districts to
apply in a competitive manner to the
Department of Education so that was part
of the 2017 budget which we know goes
into place in July 1st of 2018 the state
audit takes a you know six months to
wrap up we're not wrapped up for the say
the 24th fiscal year audit yet um in
right in the February timeline of fiscal
year
2018 that's when we knew there was $18
million available to be distributed into
this public school infrastructure fund
unfortunately it was around the same
time as the Parkland school shooting so
everybody will remember that happened in
February of
2018 and so um the primary use of these
funds at that time or it was Prior
prioritized was school safety projects
so this is it is still Tech technically
under the language of the public school
infrastructure fund so that's important
for the committee to understand but the
projects have been prioritized as far as
school safety and the majority of the
funding has been used for school safety
um so that was at first $18 million also
immediately after that school shooting
happened the legislature prioritized an
additional $10 million to be distributed
to this fund to be used for school
safety projects since then there were um
a few additional distributions there was
a million dollar I think per year in 22
and 23 um because this is a specific
fund um the money goes into the fund and
the interest earned on that is actually
distributed back into the fund so that's
help that that funds these projects um
and then unfortunately again there was
another large school shooting in 22 I
believe it was the ubaldi school
shooting and the state as a whole
allocated $10 million from the Gopher
stimulus funding to this fund to we will
to provide school safety projects and
then another $10 million of Education
trust fund funds to be distributed to
these projects um so over the life of
this um fund the public school
infrastructure fund these are the the
types of projects that have been funded
um the while larger school safety
projects were funded under the first uh
$28 million the last two grants were um
capped at $100,000 per square school um
not per District per school and there
were three types of projects that were
prioritized surveillance access control
and emergency alerting um and so the way
it works is that schools work with the
Department of Homeland Security to have
a security assessment they're also are
required to have an emergency response
plan and through that they determine
various different needs that they may
have um and then schools can apply to
the Department of Education when we have
funds available um and award funds in
the order that they were received with
prioritizing certain projects so the
very first um kind of trunch of money
with this new year of money we um the
Department of Homeland Security worked
with us and the public school
infrastructure fund committee which I
should there's a committee made up of um
legislators and the State Board of
Education um that reviews these projects
and ranks the priorities of what we'll
rank um we awarded all of the access
control projects and then remaining
funds were distributed to the
surveillance and emergency alerting
projects um let's see what didn't I
cover so how much money is in the fund
right now so 100% of the funds are
awarded to school districts we um
awarded the last bit of money uh I think
it was in the summer of 24 there's still
a weit list of I think 8 something
million dollar um what the way it works
is is so we award funds to a school and
then once a school closes out a project
say if we had a $100,000 project and
they only need $888,000 that $122,000
comes back and then we continue just
going down through the ranking project
so the last time we accepted
applications was in fiscal year 24
awarded at the end of 24 maybe early 25
forget for the timing wise um and so
right now there's no free funds um there
is I don't know seven or 8 million
that's there sitting there for schools
and they're they're working through the
projects um you some people are like
well if you wed These funds why didn't
schools immediately draw them down
sometimes it requires if it's a larger
project a school may need to put it in
their budget for the next year they may
need to additional appropriate
additional money locally they might need
to um just do you know they some of them
um they might need to wait till the kids
are out of school especially if it's a
large installation of a security project
so if we Awards a fund to somebody right
now they may wait till next summer to
install it it's all reimbursement based
so we don't pay anybody for forward so
once they incur the cost then they can
request funds from the Department of
Education and we will make the payment
and then close out the project and award
any fund to anybody else available so I
think it's $8.6 million or something
like that I can get you the exact amount
on the wait list um and if we were to do
you know a new RFP for schools they
would likely apply and and
whatnot uh representative Murray can you
say that again so there's 8 million 8
million in
requests that's outstanding let's see
and how many projects is that see the
weight lless total is actually in this
packet I think it is yeah
so yeah so actually the wait list on
this and this is a point in time so I
think we actually ran this list in
November um but so as of right now we
have a weight list of $9.2 million still
on the weight list it's on page 7 out of
s in your packet
and there were $21 million in the first
two rounds that was the last that we
didn't fund at all so we're we what we
have been historically doing is
releasing essentially a new proposal um
every bium and then all of the old
weight list goes away and they start we
start with a new weight list and that b
anym
that's it for
us we do a lot at the Department of
Education and we are really looking
forward to supporting you guys through
the budget so if you have any other
questions Mickey knows how to get a hold
of us no matter what like including on
Sundays and late at night um so you know
we'll be here to support you and answer
any questions so make sure you reach out
and we will help you with whatever weird
little nuanced question you may have
thank you thank you all very much
appreciate it and are we are we
done okay
so if you want to we can I just but I
need to announce that we're done if
we're
done all right so I'll close out the
hearing at 3 o' of the finance division
2 um work
session yeah I hope
so
e e